Oh, you said marketing is another name for hacking. I mean, instead of hacking, I mean,
hacking relates to computers, marketing relates to people, right? You're hacking people.
Yeah.
Wow.
Go watch Social Dilemma.
All right. Sup guys. I have been working my butt off on this live hacking event. So it's great to take a break and talk to you guys about this week's podcast episode that I'm super excited for because we brought on the show, John Colston, AKA mayonnaise.
John is someone you will see often at the top of the leaderboards on hacker one, because he takes a data science approach to bug bounty.
And that really helps him multiply his findings. Every, every finding that he has, he's able to sort of narrow down what kind of vulnerabilities and problems that these companies are having and apply those to other endpoints to find more bugs.
So it's a really fascinating interview. I hope you'll enjoy it. I most certainly did. In addition to that, we've also got the, uh, word fence bug bounty program running a 6.25 times promotion.
Again, if you haven't already signed up for this platform, you're crazy. You've signed up for hacker one, you've signed up for bug crowd, you signed up for integrity.
Why haven't you signed up for word fence yet? So head over to ctpb.show slash wf, sign up for a researcher account today. So you can stay in the loop and hear about these awesome promotions. Every time they come up, I've been, uh, I've been working on that program a little bit, and I've got some automation in place that is producing a good number of bugs at a set pace.
So, um, for any of you that like static code analysis, there's definitely an opportunity there to get some automation in place as well.
Alrighty. With that, let's go ahead and jump to the episode with John.
Alrighty, John, I am looking at this massive document over here to the right, right now, filled with like pretty much just gold on the crossover between data science and bug bounty.
Thanks so much for coming to the show, man. And thanks so much for all the effort you put into prepping for it.
Thanks just for having me. Yeah. Um, for those that don't know who I am, my name is John Colston. I go by the, uh, handle of many is or my own eyes or Mayo. I go through all three of those. Um, and I got into, um, into the bug bounty world about five years ago. And, uh, I've been working at it to various levels.
So, so, so dude, yeah. Mayonnaise. I've always thought about this. Mayonnaise is like pretty odd name. Give us like the, the 30 seconds summary of why you chose that name. And, and, uh, and it definitely made you a figure in the, in the bug bounty space. You're like, who's this guy calling himself mayonnaise?
Yes. So, um, it's funny. I, uh, young John was a huge fan of the smashing pumpkins and the Siamese dream album. Uh, it was one of those life changes, right? And there was a song on there and everybody called it mayonnaise, but it's, it's spelled mayonnaise with one N. Uh, and then somewhere along the years, I researched, uh, the meaning of it. And it's actually like a phonetic play. It's my own eyes.
It's sort of mayonnaise, the drop of the, my own eyes, my own eyes. And so I thought that was a cool.
It's like some weird pronunciation. Yeah. So I said, Hey, that's perfect. You know, for a hack of my own eyes, he's the stuff. And, uh, and I related to something, you know, that, uh, I enjoy, which is music. And that's how that came together.
That's awesome, man. There's so many different areas. So let me, let me back up a little bit. The reason why we wanted to bring you on the pod is, uh, time and time again, on the podcast,
the critical thinking podcast here, we have discussed the part of hacking relating to data and to taking notes on a specific target. Right. And so many of the people that we have on are just like, yeah, you know, I take notes in this astiff.txt file and it's really like rough and there's no system to it. It's just kind of like, I write things down on this paper and I stick it in my shoe or something like that. Right. It's, it's all over the place. And we're like, I was thinking, okay, we've got so many,
um, takes on that perspective. Let me get a different perspective. And I was thinking who is the most organized and who is the most methodical, you know, data driven hacker that I know. And you came to mind. So what I'm hoping to get out of today. Um, is, is a little bit of a look into how you use data science to win bug bounties. And man, if you look at your hacker one profile, you're, you're winning it, man. It's great. Um, and, and, and so I want to know about how you've done that.
And, um, I know also that you have a, uh, specific propensity for digital marketing, marketing in your past experiences and kind of how that plays into the data science into the hacking role. Um, and to get that holistic perspective, I think we're going to have to go back a little bit and hear about, um, your, your career path and your career history and how you kind of got into this digital marketing and data science areas, um, that made you the hacker you are today. So give us a little brief introduction to that, if you would.
Yeah. So, um, so, um, so I went to, uh, Georgia tech and, you know, I graduated, um, in 1999, which was the kind of the height of the.com boom. Right. My focus was in information technology.
Nice. Yeah.
Yeah. And, and, and went, went to work for a startup, um, and, um, was integrated as a, was consulted into a credit card company, was responsible of building out a lot of their information systems, um, and integrating the technology that we built was a real-time decision engine, um, to be able to approve customers for credit card real-time online. That was like new stuff.
Wow. That's a big deal.
Yeah. And, uh, so yeah, went through that, um, eventually sort of working for the credit company, um, did a new venture, I guess, underneath there that eventually got acquired because the whole lead generation, um, vertical was exploding. So got, um, into that, um,
I guess in that industry as part of an acquisition, uh, built out several national brands. Um, and with that, you know, you had my television, you know, radio, but you had an incredible amount of digital media or digital advertising that would go on. And so I was responsible as all the analytics to tie everything together, make sure that every dollar spent was accountable for generating return. And, um, worked very closely, especially with the digital man.
Uh, digital marketing team to be able to understand what levers are being pushed. How do I now provide them with the information to help them make the decisions needed to, to, um, you know, perform better and acquire customers at a lower cost and then higher volume.
So that's kind of how I got into the whole.
Now, uh, as far as like, you know, how that transitioned to, um, to bug bounty, I eventually had gone on to start doing my own, um, uh, a business that was in a business.
That was in a completely different vertical, still legion. Um, but it was in the mortgage space. Uh, we hit some walls at one point with compliance, trying to get through, um, some legal matters. And, um, I needed to figure out some, how to earn some income where we worked through those issues.
And, uh, you know, found a freelance opportunity and, uh, it was something that I was aware of. It was on my radar, but just was so busy doing this.
Anyway, so I jumped in and, um, having a background in, in, you know, data science and, and, uh, analytics and whatnot. I took that approach. I took a very biological data processing. How do I approach this type of mentality? Um, and then stuck hard to one program.
Um, and I believe that was probably a little bit of naivety, but how the bug bounty space was back then favoring loyalty. But, um, but yeah, that's kind of how I went into the space.
Wow. Dude, that's, that's such an interesting start because one of the advice pieces of advice that I give to most people that are trying to start bug bounty is like, Hey, you can't really be in a situation where you're, uh, you know, trying to enter the industry to make money because you're in some sort of, you know, situation where you, you don't have your, your finances squared down.
And, uh, not only did you know, and, and, you know, maybe not speaking to the finances part, but you were transitioning out of a, out of a, you know, a situation with your startup where you needed to find some additional income and going into the space, which adds additional pressures.
And then, you know, coming from a non-security related field and just taking that expertise from that field and applying it to bug bounty. Um, I'm not going to lie, man. I would have bet against you.
I would have bet against you. I would have bet against you that, that you wouldn't have been able to pull it off as well as you did, but you did. That's amazing.
So, so, I mean, you know, working with data, with everything, right. Uh, as I was reading up, right. A lot of had to do about hacking API. Well, okay. I'm very familiar with API.
That was not something that. So then it was like, okay, how do you, how do you find API? Right. And then, so you go through that process and then as you're reading and so much content was out there, it was basically saying, you know, you get it.
You know, you get, you know, get access to systems and you go through. Well, quickly, I realized whenever I got onto Yahoo is that, okay, one, they're in clean up, clean up mode, right.
They're one of the original advertising platforms, if not the original, original advertising platforms that were out there. So the technology was going to be old.
doubling that up over, right. Is that, okay. They're spending their time on the pub public facing assets. Right. So you knew if you can get into the business of business, the B2B type of applications, then you were going to have, um, opportunities that were going to be once in a lifetime. Right. I mean, you were going to have.
Yeah, dude, this is, this is such a, an intuitive approach, man. You're like, okay, let me just think. So if I was going to hack, I need to find APIs and how do I find APIs? Well, I find some sketchy advertising company. And I like that you went to in your vertical as well. You say that's, that's another thing we talk about a lot on the pod is like, if you can hack within your vertical, within the thing that you understand within the industry that you're familiar with, whether from a hobby perspective or from a work perspective, that's going to afford you a tremendous advantage.
Um, and that's what you did. So you went after, you went after Yahoo here. Anybody who has ever looked at the Yahoo leaderboard knows that you went after Yahoo. Um, and, and, uh, you were finding APIs left and right. And you were trying to get your hands on these, these, uh, business B2B applications or some of this old stuff.
Right. Right. Exactly. And so, you know, when you find the APIs and this goes back to the journal you're talking about, right. Uh, I would find those APIs. They're not vulnerable at that point in time, but they, they provide a wealth of information. So whenever I do get access or whatever, or it helps me identify, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey.
Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey, Hey
Yahoo and AOL had gone through all these murders and acquisitions. I mean, you had all these other bolt on ad platforms that were out there. So it was just, it was a garden of opportunity. Yeah, yeah. And all of it was, you know, all these, I say a mess, he says a garden.
Garden of opportunity that just needed to be harvested.
So that's great, man. I love that.
So I signed up for that job.
Yeah, no, clearly, clearly, clearly. And so, you know, you stuck for the beginning, you know, you kind of stuck into your, into your vertical there and you're looking at Yahoo spending a lot of time on them. Um, I guess, and, and nowadays, are you still looking at Yahoo primarily, or you have you kind of moved along? How has your methodology evolved from those early times to now, nowadays?
Yeah. So, um, you know, John Colson mayonnaise, 2024 is completely different than 22. Right. Um, and so back in the day, I was, I was fully committed, um, and spent an insane amount of time focusing on Yahoo.
And neither the opportunity was limited and, and, and the boundaries were good. And, um, so I just went so deep. Um, and, and when I went going deep on applications, it wasn't necessarily going deep into the technology.
It was going, you know, finding if there were any seminars in that were out there or public education, you know, the B2B type thing, what were some of the things that were being pushed out to the industry that I could then say, okay, Hey, you know, they're, they're releasing some new technology called immersion.
Okay. And I need to figure out what that is. Where does that live? The things to that niche. So I would, I'd use that also as a, as a lead, um, to be able to try to find, uh, things on the platform and go from there.
Um, and so, yeah.
So about that, would you, would you automate that actual part of it yourself or was this just you kind of being plugged into the data sources for Yahoo and like what's happening with the platform and that sort of thing?
Both. So the, I mean, the automation was, it was constantly, so constantly going after and finding what are the new assets that were coming out.
Um, looking at the, uh, the domain names and say, Hey, this is a word I'm not familiar with. Is that a new product? So, you know, do I need to search this more?
And it would dovetail them to a lot of manual, um, searching and looking for, you know, documentations that, you know, a development team would use to integrate their system into their, you know, into the ad system, because they, you know,
we've got a bunch of stuff to do to be able to determine, you know, my budgets and where I'm going to put placement and things of that nature.
So they're there. These companies are tied into multiple platforms. And so there's integrations that go on. So there's documentation flying around on that kind of stuff as well.
Right. Right.
Um, so yeah, and all that kind of, uh, all those things were what I was used to be able to help guide me and identify those places. It was, I mean, I don't know how many platforms I was able to get to and put my hands on.
Um, but yeah, that was, that was my, that was my goal.
Dude, the, the layer that the depth there, right. I just want to point out, you know, the fact that you said, Hey, there's a monitoring subdomains, right.
Which is, you know, something that's fairly normal in the bug bounty industry. It's something we do. And then he says, and there was a word I didn't re I didn't know.
Like, like this is, this is the level of granularity that I feel like a lot of people don't realize that you need in bug bounty because, you know, when you look at the list of, you know, 20,000 subdomains or more that you get back from, you know, uh, running a subdomain enumeration scan on Yahoo.
Uh, it can be overwhelming, but then John says, Hey, there's actually a new subdomain that just popped up with a word that I don't know in it.
Let me go and research what's happening with this company. Let me try to figure out what transitions are happening at this current time with the company and dive deep into that.
So that's, that's amazing, man.
It can expose a new product, a new platform, a new technology. Um, yeah. So yeah. Understanding what, you know, what the domain names provide you, uh, gives you a hint of what's going on.
Uh, gives you a hint of what's going on behind the scene.
So, so there's the new stuff that's happening, the new transitions that are happening with the company. There's the old, old, old stuff that you're getting access to, you know, these antiquated applications.
Um, you've said in the notes here, you know, somewhere that it was like stuff that, that was sort of pre-security life cycle. Like security wasn't even a thought really at the time when some of these applications were being developed because it was so, you know, long ago.
Um, and so getting access to those core applications is important, but that's tricky, right? Getting access to, uh, some of these more complex, um, more, uh, niche, uh, platforms.
So, I mean, were you mostly hacking from an unauthenticated perspective? Did you, how did, how did you get your hands on credentials or how did you actually hack these platforms?
So, yeah. So, um, ultimately you had to get, well, many percent of the time you had to get credentials, right? Um, so a lot of the, a lot of the automation hacking would build a portfolio of documents that you would then silo into, okay, this is probably AOL one, or this is, you know, DSP or something.
Right. Right. Right. So you had the wealth of the documentation, not only, and then you'd find, um, so, you know, the, the typical way that you, you go about, um, is okay. Can I find a place to brute force? Okay. That's limited. Um, but even with the limitations, you know, being on the business side of things, and this is a good tip to take back, right?
If you're on a hacking, a B2B system and, um, you know, that at some point they're going to have demo accounts or test accounts so that they can share with other businesses.
Okay. So if you're able to identify in some capacity that, okay, it's demo at blah, yahoo.com or whatever, and it, and you, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're, you're,
right. So that's one way. Another way, especially on the B2B is that if you can figure out who are the users, like which businesses have used the platform and you're able to assemble that
and monitor which of those companies go out of business
and then buy their domain, buy their domain and then
and then you can approach. So there was a fortunate, you know, I was able to download a list
and then I memorized every user in that list and all the domains
because you can't save it. That's great. I love it.
All of them, right. And, uh, no, and then, you know, I monitor and see, okay,
is that GoDaddy has a great tool for that. This is domain available. Oh, it is. Okay.
Let me register that domain and create an email address. Okay. And then now,
Let me try to do some, let me, let me do a password reset.
No way.
So now two-factor authentication has kind of taken over that, right? And, and if, even if you get, even if you get, if you brute force an account or you, um, do some time account take over that,
I'm telling you're nine times out of 10, you're going to get a hard stop from the, from the company.
Like, okay, great. Right.
The bug in's there. Um, I do recommend saying, Hey, uh, once I get in, and I didn't poke around much,
but I like to see what I can do in the next X hours. Would that be possible?
You might get a reprieve.
Yeah.
Um, and, and, you know, permission to go in. Uh, but ultimately I think that the, you know, if you can figure out a way to overcome whatever barriers it is to get an account in your own credentials,
then they can't stop you. They can't stop you.
Yeah.
So, uh, I would highly recommend that.
That's amazing.
So, so you can also, you know, so that's ways that we can sort of compromise accounts with, with, um, you know, trying to brute force some stuff or, or be able to do passive resets on people's domains have expired.
Um, and then getting your own account, that's a whole different beast, right?
Cause like you, you have to, in those scenarios, you kind of got to, you kind of be able, got to be able to walk the walk and talk the talk to say like, Hey, yeah, I know about this product.
Yeah, I'm interested in using this product for my business, that sort of thing and getting that all set up.
Have you, have you had experience with that?
Uh, yeah.
So, um, I have tried many different times, failed quite a bit whenever you, you know, it's trying to tend to be a business.
Um, I think the, my favorite story to tell is, um, is obtaining access to the Taiwan assets, uh, of Yahoo.
Um, because those assets required, um, a physical presence within the country and a phone number.
Um, and so, and I, and maybe even an additional ID, but there was a, it was a huge barrier unless you were in Taiwan, uh, you, you were very limited.
So I, um, through several attempts, the first three or four failed, but the finally figured out the winning methodology is that I posted a job on Upwork.
Um, and I was looking for an English translator.
And, and it was, you had to be where I failed is that I was like, try to hire them on.
And then I'm telling them what I would do.
And they were like, no, I'm not going to hack.
No.
And they would go away.
So in the job posting, I said, lifetime opportunity, right?
Shotgun with a hacker is we blah, blah, blah, blah.
And go after.
And.
Dude.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
The response board just lit up.
Like it was like immediately slow down.
And so, um, I was able to find, uh, this wonderful lady named Lexi in, uh, Taiwan.
And she, uh, she had a family member that actually had, uh, the, you know, uh, the mall and store and all that that had those accounts.
And she was, you know, enough familiar.
So we're like, all right, let's go.
And we registered and it was like, no way.
Yeah.
We went through the whole process and registered and, uh, she was in my eyes and ears and, and got me in.
And yeah, no, it was, uh, right timing for, uh, for a live hacking event.
And it was just, it was, everything was great.
Um, that's amazing.
So, so this, you know, you went through those, you jumped through those hoops and then you've got yourself an account and.
Now you've got access to the scope that nobody has access to.
Exactly.
And you've got creds and you've got all these old APIs and, you know, beginning of the marketing era.
Uh, tools that you've got them all to yourself.
Wow.
Yeah.
That is crazy.
I mean, I'll be always, I'll be, I'll always admit, like, I mean, my skill as a, as a hacker is.
It's secondary, right.
Um, compared to like when I watch.
When you guys talk about, oh yeah, we inserted a hyperlink with this tag and then we redirected and then we somehow got a heat dump in which we had the creds for the entire company on AWS.
I mean, okay, fantastic.
I'm not going to go there.
That's my skillset.
But if I can get to assets that, you know, that, or that are in, uh, in line, more of my skillset, then I'm going to, that's what I'm doing.
So that was, that's how I went after things.
Uh, that's great, man.
Yeah, that's great, man.
And, and this whole, this whole concept of, of going deeper and deeper and deeper than people.
People think you should go or people think you, you, uh, have to go to find these various assets and get access to these systems and understand the company at a deeper level.
That's one of the core, core things that's really important in Vagani and you've kind of nailed it.
Um, so we, we've talked a good bit about that.
Um, I want to swing back around to the, so we're, we're going to go two places here.
We're going to go the data.
We want to talk about data science and how you use data science to, you know, uh, more specifically granularly, how you're using that in your recon flow, how you're using it to predict vulnerabilities and that sort of thing.
And then I also want to talk about specific, cause clearly you have a lot of industry expertise on digital marketing.
I want to talk about digital marketing platforms in particular in some sort of, um, I guess, you know, hands on the keyboard or, you know, looking at the data, uh, tips and tricks for, um, how to do that.
So let's, let's start with, let's start with data science.
Um, obviously for me, let me just kind of give a little brain dump of what I'm thinking here.
So when I think data science plus bug bounty, I'm thinking mostly from a recon perspective, but if you look at your hacker one file profile, you're not just doing recon, you're finding a lot of bones.
So I'm wondering how, how much of your methodology with that uses data science is, is pertaining to reconnaissance and how much of it actually gives you a, a tangible vulnerability.
And, um, and then I guess you can kind of talk about either one of those recon and, and the actual, uh, vulnerability itself.
Yes.
So, um, figuring out how to best approach this and, and, um, explain it.
So data science, um, I use it as a construct.
It's not a one and done type thing, applying it to, to word list.
It's, it's applying it to, uh, everything I do.
Um, and so to do that, um, I go under the mantra, uh, Peter Drucker, he's a, he's a management, um, philosopher.
He, he came up with this saying is what is not measured is not managed.
Right.
And so when you, when you put everything into that framework is that you want to measure everything.
And because if you, if you're able to measure it, then you're able to optimize it.
So, um, to, to do that in, you know, bug bounty, most of us are, whenever I watch.
I actually use the tools there are one and done, right.
It's not built into some system that's intended to keep track of performance that you can then later go back at a future date and make modifications and do your optimization.
So I built a system that whenever I run a fuzz on a target, right.
It's going to log everything that I do.
So I have wrappers around all my tools and I call, I call the, that, that worker with this and then make sure that all that information goes into.
Uh, well, I say a database, but it's flat files that I can later use.
Okay.
I'm going to pause you right there because there's just so much to unwind just right there.
So first, first step, first step is we need to measure everything so that we can optimize everything so that we can perform better as bug bounty hunters.
In order to do that, what you've done is you've wrapped all of your tools with some sort of, um, I guess some sort of script or something that is going to be taking the output of that tool.
And allowing you to retrieve the output later if you need to, or can you just talk a little bit, it's going into flat files and you know, you say a database, but it's going into flat files.
And then you're searching those flat files for patterns that you've identified.
Is that the idea?
So, okay.
So yeah, it was next, next level.
So let's just take, we have one file that we're fuzzing, right?
And it's a generic file and you're fuzzing it on all domains.
Right.
So let's take a look at all the ways that we can measure.
So we have a domain, right?
We know what the program is.
We know the sub domain of that program or whatever the root is, right?
Those are two pieces of traceability that you need to have.
Right.
So you not only domain sub domain and program, right?
Then, um, you give it the file.
How big is that file?
What is the purpose of that file?
And can I track it?
So I know the identity of it.
Right.
So how many records in, right?
How many records out?
How many successful hits did it have?
And your definition of successful hit could be different between people, whatever.
Right.
So now I have a hit rate for that file by that program, by that root.
Okay.
So now I can start seeing, okay, this particular file is going to have a performance of X on here.
So now whenever you start looking at the bigger picture things, I have a hit rate of X percent here and Y percent here.
Why is that?
Right.
Okay.
This, this, then you start getting to the topics of relevancy and, and all that stuff.
Right.
So that's a very generic.
You're correlating.
Yes.
So I can see, I'm starting to see it here.
So, so, you know, you say, okay, I ran this across this specific set of sub domains.
I'd expect I get this specific hit rate.
I run it across this sub domains.
And wow, this hit rate is specifically, you know, drastically different.
What, what is, am I doing something wrong here?
It does this file just not exist on these sub domains, but they, they're, they should exist.
So maybe a certain, you know, path is mapped wrong or incorrectly or differently or something like that.
And wow.
Okay.
So, so applying it to flat files, you're not going to have that much of a difference, but whenever you start, whenever you start getting into your like specific files that, okay.
So all my files have a unique purpose, like I have a purpose, this file is meant to find APIs.
This file is meant to find endpoints that reveal directory structures or additional endpoints within the server.
This file is meant for fine upload features.
I don't, you, you have, right.
You'll quickly be able to start finding things accordingly by program, by, you know, the actual route within the program.
And be able to see what you're doing well and what you're doing not.
Right.
If you can identify, okay, here are my top performers.
Here's my 10 top performers.
Why, why, why is it performing well?
What is happening here that I can then.
So where I'm going is that whenever you take a look and you just look at your standard, your output of it, how do you, how do you measure it?
How do you, how do you know you're improving on your fuzzing?
How do you know that your word list is applicable or relevant to this file or to this program or this program or this program?
So now, now once you build a, and this is a bit of an overkill.
I, I, and the only reason why I do this is because.
Hey, you said, you said it, not me, man.
I don't know.
It's an overkill.
And, and, and, and, and, and what I only hope is that, you know, for people, for the audiences, listen here is that you can take a little tidbit.
So in, you don't have to build out this master system, but, but being able to understand, you know, how to put together a construct so you can start measuring performance across.
You know, different programs, different word lists, different sections.
So how's your crawler doing?
You know, how's your link finder doing?
You know, why is it clearly I'm missing out on some keywords for this program because it's hit rate is very low.
What's unique about it?
Let me try to spend some extra time fuzzing on it to see if there's okay.
There's a different path to, you know, the files that I normally use to be able to determine like a director structure.
So it kind of identifies areas where you can focus and then whatnot.
So you're, you're assigning performance, you're measuring even down to like the, the path in the directory level and creating lists and analytics that are, are telling you about the efficiency of specific, like, directory brute forcing list entries.
It's just granularly.
Yeah.
And, and where it goes in is, okay.
Wow.
So I have, so I have, so as I have workflows, right.
And so my, one of my main workflows goes through a series and it looks something like this.
It's like quick hit fuzz of like things that's going to reveal director structure on, right.
And some of the API, but a lot of it's like robots.txt asset manifest things that nature.
Right.
Sure.
Okay.
There's tools that can like this concepts can be applied to people that not necessarily
are wanting to build out full automation.
You can build out, you can use this concept to build out.
Okay.
I'm going to do a new keyword discovery tool, right?
Because I need to add and grow my word less.
Okay.
Well, let's use that.
So I want to, I want to hear about, I want to hear about that.
And, and I want to also go back to what you were saying before about tracing the vulnerability.
Now you found the vulnerability.
Let me see what parts of my process led to me finding that end point, which we found to
that vulnerability.
But first I want to get a little bit into the weeds on how exactly you're doing this.
Cause I was like, when I hear you talk about, um, statistical analysis on paths and, and stuff
like that, I'm like, wow, that sounds really cool.
I should have all of my word lists sorted by, Hey, this is the ones that are going to hit first,
you know, uh, statistically across, you know, a big set of data.
Um, but, but I'm a little bit like when I start thinking about how I'm going to program that and how I'm going to do that,
it gets a little bit, it gets a little bit fuzzy for me.
So, I mean, obviously how are you, you said you mentioned flat files, uh, you said database and then you're like, oh, well, it's actually flat files.
Yeah.
I mean, are you, are you computing efficiency for these specific, um, paths and then like storing them in a flash file or in a flat file and like CSV format and then like dumping it in after you've sorted it with, I don't know.
How are you doing this?
Yeah.
It's not quite as automated as, as what you're going.
It's just collecting the data that leads me to the information or that are at least you need to where I can start diving.
So let's say this process that has X number of sub processes, right?
I'm going to like, I know what each sub process does.
So I know the word list that it uses, but I'm going to count in, okay.
How many in, uh, how many records in how many hits.
Right.
And I'm going to dump that to a KPI log.
So for this, the process, this is the end that's out and this is the time duration because whenever you, where I'm, where I'm going with this is that I want, at the end of the day, I want to sit down, have a cup of coffee, spend two hours writing reports and then, and then go play golf.
I mean, that's what I want.
That's what I want.
But that's, that's, that's the end goal.
I'm not trying to be like, I'm not trying to be like, I'm not trying to be like, I'm not trying to be like, oh, I can tolerate this great attack vector.
And I am what I am.
I call this practice retirement right now.
I'm figuring out what I'm going to do, but I, I, I'm, you know, I'm, uh, I'm living the good life.
I'm taking, uh, my intensity down a bit.
And if I can have these systems generate a list of what I call opportunities.
I'm basically, I'm building a lead generation platform for hackers.
It's going to give me leads at the end of the day.
There's going to be opportunities.
And that's a great way to call it right there.
It's lead gen for volumes.
Yeah, exactly.
That's exactly what I'm trying to build.
That's flat.
I'm not, I'm not doing, it's not vulnerability scanning.
Well, that is part of it.
You know, you can run nuclei, nuclei all day long, uh, and find, and find stuff there.
But this is, this is stuff that is tailored just to me.
Right.
And so let's say, let's say there's another hacker that eventually partner up with that is like, oh, I'm like, a game is SQL injection.
Okay.
What are your flags?
Let me program it in.
Here's your feed.
Right.
And so that's kind of where I'm going with it.
So, wow.
That, so, so, okay.
So, but your, your, your key, your key performance indicators there is, is, um, you know, your inputs, uh, you know, you're saying, okay, I'm fuzzing this file, you know, this file of, um, uh, you know, let's say you said, you mentioned quick hits before, right?
We've got like quick hits.txt or whatever.
And, um, we fuzz that on a target and then we'd say, okay, uh, it took this much time.
Uh, there's this many hits and, uh, this many, you know, uh, yeah, I guess this many entries in the thing.
So you can say, okay, you know, my percent, my success rate on this specific word list is X percent.
Uh, and then, but, but you're probably not breaking it down further than that and saying, okay, well, let me take the 6% that hit.
No, okay.
Because that's just a little bit crazy because then at that point, you'd have to actually have a database.
Yeah.
Well, eventually you do from the standpoint of, okay, you know, what was in contained in the file, you know, what your hits were, you know, which like, so you could filter down and say, okay, just give me just the hits that have happened.
I ain't put it in.
It's more of making sure that you're not going completely out of rounds.
Did that file run in 20 seconds?
Okay.
I'm fine.
I guess it's just the initial stage.
I don't want it to be, um, I don't want it to be a hog, but as you go through my process, I'm bolting on and adding new stuff and I'm building word lists on the fly dynamically based upon what's been.
Um, so what words are in the domain?
Okay.
Those need to be fuzz and you'd be fuzzed in a certain pattern and what, you know, words, you know, X and a link finder find out that are say, Hey, these are relevant to the target.
Those need to put in some type of, um, recipe ingredient combination that can then go into be fuzz.
Right.
So, you know, let's say you're going through and you see an outlier and all of a sudden that, okay, there, you found this one step of your process where, you know, all of a sudden there were 5 million keywords.
That were like, Whoa, wait, what happened here?
Right.
Now you're able to go in and not that from an optimization standpoint, say, okay, what specifically occurred here?
Because that's messed up.
I don't ever want that to happen.
Um, or you can, or you can say, Hey, this, this particular key, you know, recipe in my keyword.
Um, is working really well.
Okay.
How can I find other variants of that that they can then add in?
So, oh, is it, it's V2 word.
Internal.
I don't know what it, okay.
Well, let's, let's, uh, let's go in and find the three, four, five, one.
That's so, that's so data driven.
I love that because it's like, one of the things that I often do is I I'll, I'll get excited about that and I'll get all the data and I'll get it in a database and I'll be like, all right, I got all the data.
You know?
Right.
And then I won't even necessarily go back and be like, okay, well, what, what paths.
Really have been performing well across this whole, you know, this whole target.
And what can I extrapolate from that?
It's all about extrapolation in these sort of contexts too.
It's like looking at your, the things that you've done that have succeeded in saying, hey, why did these succeed and how can I, how can I replicate that?
Um, and, and actually I, I mentioned, you know, a couple of times on the pod before that I was really into recon back in the day.
And, um, I, I implemented, uh, something similar to this, uh, where I would, you know, even just parsing the words from the, the domain name, not nothing else, just the domain name and using those words to enumerate other domain names.
And, and this whole concept that we were talking about, uh, uh, off air, uh, of recipes and, and, uh, ingredients and that sort of thing.
And that man, I was blown away by the results, man.
There there's just a ton of stuff you you'll, you'll miss because it's not in security trails.
It's not in, you know, any of this other stuff.
Um, and, but it is there when you start mixing, you know, mixing, matching all these words together.
So two questions with that, um, one, how do you get your ingredients?
Um, you mentioned that you're using words related to the target.
You know, you're pulling it from various tools.
Um, let's say you've got a domain.
It's all words just smushed together.
How do you tell where the word starts and begins?
Okay.
Well, so, um, one is that, um, data science is used for probability.
It's not to get a hundred percent.
So if let's say there's a domain that is like 36 characters long and there's no dashes and dots.
Okay.
That's a one off.
How many other domains are you ever going to see that like that again?
So just stay a wash.
Hey, let that one go.
It's not worth my time to find that.
Um, so yeah, so I break down, I break down, um, the domains, uh, subdomains.
So actually let's start back.
We've got all of our different data repositories that we're pulling up.
From all that information comes in.
All right.
You have ones that resolve ones that don't resolve just because they don't resolve.
Doesn't mean they don't have value.
Make sure you store something resolved in the past, you know, exactly.
It can resolve in the future.
So it could resolve on the backend, you know?
Yeah, still.
Yes.
You know, you can still, still keep trying to resolve it over the next 30 days or so.
Whatever.
Right.
Okay.
So now you've got this information.
Right.
Um, and what you start looking for is frequency.
Frequency of words.
So you break it down.
So let's do, um, a quick example.
Yeah.
You got, I don't know, 10,000 subdomains.
You break it down by the dashes and dots.
And, um, sometimes you leave dashes together, whatever.
And then you do a free.
Mm-hmm.
Do a frequency of what is showing up.
So you're going to see API, you can see admin, you can see internal, you can see blah, blah, blah, blah.
Right.
And then what you're going to realize is.
Yeah.
So as you go through and said, let's say you take the top, you know, a hundred words.
Everything you say, okay, what does this fall into?
Okay.
So this is an API ingredient.
So API API one, YQL, blah, blah, blah.
Those are all.
You're manually doing this.
You have to, right.
I mean, there has to be some type of.
In the beginning for sure.
Yeah.
I mean, so, so your group in your, and you'll find that, um, there, there's not crazy amounts of, you might get in like the specifics of, you know, there might be a particular company that puts some data in the data.
There might be a particular company that puts their co-location in the mix.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, and so the, the nuance of that and being able to go through and understand that you, you put together a list of ingredients, a word list of each ingredient as you go through.
And the word list is to tell you what the ingredients are based on the frequency of what's been shown up in the past.
All right.
So now you've got the ingredients.
So now build a loop that says that replaces those words in your 10,000 domains with the ingredient name.
Right.
And then now you start, okay.
Re-summarize that up.
And then now you start to see, okay.
And, oh, and if, and if there's, and if at the end, if there's, you haven't fully identified all the things, just have it insert a generic word.
Like this word goes here.
Right.
So that way you can then start summarizing up and then say, okay, what are my recipes?
All right.
So it's, you know, API, you know, internal, some word.
Version number of the word.
Yeah.
Environment.
Yes.
Blah, blah, blah.
Right.
And you'll say, oh, there's, there's my, there, I hear, here's here 20 recipes that may be specific to that program.
We may be very generic for all programs.
I mean, it depends on what you start with.
Right.
And, and so now.
And.
You see this a lot with, with stuff that with a lot of, across a lot of companies and you'll also see stuff like, like AWS region and, and like you mentioned, you know, prod QA, that sort of thing all over the place.
And yeah, these could be relevant specifically to the company, or these could be across all, all companies.
It's just a human thing.
Um, so correlating those as well.
That's, that's great.
So you've got your ingredients.
You've broken those down by the dots and the dashes.
Um, I haven't done any word splitting, uh, just mostly done, done it that way.
And then you've got, you've, you've identified and you've grouped your words.
So you said, okay, API words would be API one, API two, a, you know, that sort of thing.
Or, or like, uh, maybe it's like backend API, back API, you know, so something like that.
And then you've got those sort of groups and then you do all of the combinations of all of them, resolve all of them.
Um, and then that tells you, I mean, obviously you, you'll definitely identify some of the, uh, additional hosts that, that you didn't have, uh, that were based off of those patterns.
Um, but I'm wondering what other, other takeaways as well.
You have, you have from that where you can say, okay, uh, this specific word is particularly high frequency or high performing.
How can I replicate the success elsewhere?
Yeah.
So I use, are you talking about like using that same methodology and like a content discovery?
Well, absolutely.
There's definitely, there's definitely that piece.
And, and so you've got, you've got, um, you've got a list of ingredients and recipes and you've hit, you've enumerated a bunch of subdomains.
And now, um, we're, we're going an extra lay down.
And so you're using this as well for content discovery.
Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
Absolutely.
So let's talk about content discovery, right?
Okay.
So, um, let's say, uh, all right.
So, so you're in, you're in your fuzzing stage, right?
And not mentioned like there's three processes in mind and that this is a number.
I don't think exactly how many of they are.
All right.
So it goes down on.
So now we're going to start looking for words that are relevant because relevant is a very important aspect of finding content.
Let's take whatever's relevant.
All right.
So we know that the domain words are relevant because it provides information.
You're going to find three letter acronyms.
You're going to find products.
You're going to find things of that nature that are listed in there.
All right.
So now through your history, if you have it, so now you've got years worth of fuzz history that you've now captured over time.
Right.
And kind of say, okay, what, what are, what are, what are some of the paths that you commonly see whenever, um, a, um, you know, a word is listed in domain?
How does it, how does it apply to like finding APIs?
Right.
So you take a look at it, you're like, okay, but it, I've noticed now that it takes a word from the domain.
All right.
And I do domain dash API dash.
Swagger dot Jason.
Right.
And so you start adding in and start playing around with, okay, how, how do I take the information that I have?
And then how do I then apply it extremely relevant and abbreviated?
So it's quick.
Dude, I love this.
So then there's an extra layer of this here.
So now, now we say, okay, what do I know about domains that have this recipe or what do I know about domains that have an API group keyword in it?
And then you, you can cross reference it because some other host has some weird, you know, get all URLs.
Or way back, you know, entry on a different domain.
And it's not even the same API, you know, string, but it's in the same API group.
And so you take, you know, but cause you're correlating it with the API group directly, you're grabbing that string, that path, and you're trying it on this totally other host, totally different other host.
Yeah.
Because you've drawn the, the, the connection between those groups.
Wow.
Dude, this is, this is, this is crazy.
Okay.
So now let's talk about, go to the next level.
And this, this is something I recommend for the automation.
Take it to the next level from there.
Okay.
All right.
I'm listening, John.
Let's go.
All right.
So, so there is, there is this need to always look for new keywords, right?
And grow your list and building.
So when we, when we start, right, we're given a keyword list that we download from SecOps, right?
Or we, I'm going to say Jay Haddix because I think he's amazing.
I'm going to do the all.text, right?
Mm-hmm.
Whenever I first started, the most frustrating thing is that there was no context, right?
Every word was of equal weight.
When I know that some words are much more, more valuable than others.
All right.
Yeah.
So let's, let's take a, let's take a sample where, okay.
Over time we have now, if we're doing a bunch of, well, so let's, let's, let's say you got 10,000 domains, but you know, you get 10,000 domains.
Some you're interested in, some are, some are not, doesn't matter.
Okay.
Still throw them in there.
Right.
And take whatever word list you got and create some loop process, bash processes.
Basically say, okay, I want you to take the first thousand of that list.
And I want you to fuzz these 10,000 domains.
And I want you to dump the results.
And then I want you to go back and get the next thousand and then the next thousand, the next thousand, the next thousand.
And you're just dumping, dumping the results, dumping the results, dumping the rows, right?
Now, now you've got something that provides you with some, what are my hit rates for each one of those words, right?
Now I took a list of 2 million, right?
And now I've scrubbed out and now I've got, you know, these with, you know, a thousand hits.
And I've got these with two hits, right?
You now start to build weight.
And then whenever you start taking a look at weight, and then you can say, okay, you did that first, you know, 2 million that you got from SecOps.
Maybe you go get a bunch of stuff from the asset notes that comes in, which continually feeding this machine.
And that's just, okay, D-dupe, have I ever, have I ever fuzzed this before?
Yes or no?
Okay, no, I haven't.
Okay, just toss it in.
And it's just grinding in the background.
Just set up a server that does nothing but this, right?
And then put a reminder on your calendar so you can put in another, you know, 2 million or whatever, right?
Or you're finding like some patterns, whatever.
And you're like, okay, let's see what happens if I do config v2, right?
And then do every iteration of that.
It just sits and runs in the background on, you know, and then you're just occasionally going and it's like, oh, this is interesting.
This is something that has a high relative rate.
I need to start looking into this more and then starting adding that into.
So if I can, before I start adding new keywords into my production files, I want to, I want to know that they're relevant, right?
I just don't want to throw fudge at the wall and see what sticks.
I do that outside.
I want to protect my core process.
Wow.
That's great.
So then we're waiting, we're waiting at that level too.
And wow, this is, this is just, you know, I knew that your process here was pretty in depth.
This is a lot deeper than I, than I thought actually.
So, so I'm, I'm very impressed.
And, um, there's, I'm sure there's so much more we could dive into with regards to like where you're getting all of these, these data sources.
Um, and, uh, you know, how, how you're actually going that deep to, to, you know, correlate all these.
Um, but I w I want to, I want to do two things.
One, I want to, um, emphasize what you said just a moment ago, which was you went through and you categorized what words belong to what conceptual group.
And I think that this is something that a lot of hackers would have a little bit of a stigma against because it's like, I'm going to go through here and I'm going to manually say, okay, this belongs to this group.
This belongs to this group.
And you, it's a manual process, especially automationists in general, don't love, uh, you know, manual processes, but that specific thing that you did requires a human brain and it requires you to be able to look at it and say, uh, this is, you know, and sort of empathize with the developer and say, that's, that's what they were thinking when they, when they did this word, this, these two ideas are drawn together by nature of, you know, how words work and that sort of thing.
Um, and so using that extra little bit of human touch, I think is a, is an extra step that a lot of people don't go and is really necessary in the data science world that that whole categorization piece.
Right.
Um, uh, that that's very cool.
Is there any other scenarios like that, that you could, you could, um, explain to us and then, and then we'll talk about data sources and where you're getting, um, you know, like security trails and that sort of thing.
As far as like manual classification.
Um, yeah, I mean, there's, oh, I mean, it's so built into my processes.
Uh, I trying to think.
There's, there's so many manual things that I do, right.
I mean, you can't automate everything you want to be able to look at, at, at stuff.
Um, especially.
Let's talk to me about your manual processes.
Then this, this will be great because you know, someone who does lean a lot into automation, I want to know what you do manually.
Yeah.
So my manual stuff is now that I've got a system that collects all the data, I ask questions.
Right.
And the main stuff is investigating.
Like I know what I'm monitoring, but what else should I be monitoring?
What else can I find?
So if I can, if I can spot a, uh, trend, um, with like, um, you know, some type of directory structure, right.
That has a decent head rate.
Okay.
Let me come up with a way to create a hundred thousand variants of that.
Run it through and see if I get any hits that didn't make it to the production.
The hell.
And I might find four bugs while I'm doing that just in the discovery process.
That's a, that's manual.
Right.
Um, the process is doing what it's doing.
That's great.
The concept.
Let's take that example really quick and say, okay, walk me through that.
So for you, what, what that looks like is I'm going to my, my logging into my server and I'm saying, Hey, what has, what paths have the highest hit rate?
Yeah.
So, so yeah, I mean, you can, you can kind of go through that, but you know, as you're going through data, you'll see stuff that sticks out.
Like you'll see, um, you know, like you're doing like API, all of a sudden you start seeing with all this crawl and whatnot, you're starting to see swaggers with variables on it.
That's interesting.
Mm-hmm .
How many other swaggers do I have with variables do I have on it?
Oh, right.
Can I hit it without the variable?
I can't.
Okay.
So how many swaggers am I missing?
And since you, it leads you down a path.
It's like, okay, well, shit, I need to figure out what variables I do.
Okay.
Can I go to big data query?
Can I go to asset?
No.
Can I find examples of this in any type of live rate?
What am I, what are some examples?
Okay.
It's group one group two.
That's a, that's a trend.
Okay.
So let me do, you know, a bunch of different tests and that's going to go out against all those domains and see if I can pick up something like something that I missed or, or pick up on something that is, is being labbed out.
Maybe, maybe it's like, oh man, here, what my variable values should be part of the, you know, the word list that gets dumped out from XML link finder.
Oh, what if I add that in?
Right.
And, or, you know, so the manual process is getting in there, getting your hands dirty and asking the questions and being able to pull out the data.
You don't know what you don't know.
Yeah.
And you gotta, that's where most of my manual acts, but this is.
And for that, are you, are you, are you mostly like looking at, do you have, are you picking a random host and being like, okay, what is this?
What questions can I ask about this host?
Or are you looking at the data from an overall perspective and saying, okay, this host has, um, you know, a 12% higher hit rate than other hosts.
So I'm going to look at this one, or maybe I'm going to look at the one that doesn't have a very high hit rate because something's weird there.
Or how do you, how do you, how do you decide?
Yeah.
So, yes.
So, so actually what happens, so most of those hit rate stuff for the most part is going to be more operational.
Make sure I stay within line.
I'm not going outside.
My target is four minutes, five minutes at max on a, on a, if I can get through three, three thousand, uh, targets on one server a day.
Fantastic.
Right.
But the men dialed into that.
So what happens for me is I go through all this automation process, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
We'll talk about the conversion funnel, but anyway, at the output, put at the conversion funnel at the very end is, is, is, is a, is a log file for me.
Um, that, uh, that basically has said what it's discovered the end points.
It tells me, um, whether what method was used to get push, pull, blah, blah, blah.
Uh, it tells me, um, our get post, get pull, get post.
Ah, okay.
I see.
Yes.
Um, what method was used, um, what stage of the process it found.
So if it's a four or three on a crawl, that's going to be more interesting to me than a four or three on a fuss.
Cause it's much more relevant.
Right.
So now I, now I have a little information.
Okay.
If I'm gonna spend some time doing four or three bypass, I'm gonna do it on the crawl versus, you know, so I'm gonna wait that accordingly.
Right.
And then, and then I'm looking at all the end points, right?
I look at all the end points and I'll see something that I had not expected to see.
There's something that comes out.
I was like, interesting.
I've never seen this before.
Or if I am diving, like, um, is it host?
It's interesting.
And I'm diving in and I'm, you know, crawling it and I'm, you know, messing around with burp and I'll find something interesting on that.
I'm like, Oh, Hey, I need to look at this.
I have all the, excuse me.
I have all the data historically stored.
Now I can then, now that identified as a question that needs to be asked, let me go answer that question with the data that they put it.
Wow, man.
I, the, the, the breath of it all is, is a little overwhelming to me as somebody who doesn't really do data science on all this.
So then, you know, you, you get this question.
Does that make sense?
Cause I want to make sure that, does that make sense?
Cause I want to make sure that that point gets through.
It does.
So, you know, you're looking at a specific coast, you're saying, okay, I'm waiting things like, like crawling versus, uh, you know, hitting various paths.
I'm, I'm, I'm hitting, I'm waiting source, probably, um, status codes and, and waiting, um, you know, all these different attributes of the domain method used, you know, get, get post put whatever.
Um, and, and then, you know, you're looking at the interesting things from there.
Um, that, that all makes sense.
And then you find something interesting, you know, through manually looking through it, actually, at the end of the day, you've actually got to do the hacking, right?
You've got to read and you've got to put together the attack vector in your brain.
Um, and then, you know, there's this, you're looking at all this in the log file.
Um, and so, you know, then you go back to ask the data or a question about X, Y, Z thing.
And, and I guess I imagine this doesn't take a normal shape, right?
And this is the sort of thing that's a little bit hard for me to wrap my head around.
Um, but you know, you, you've got some, something like, Hey, uh, where do I see a 403s or something like that?
Should I pay attention to 403s on the specific endpoint?
How, I mean, are you just running a grep across all of your, you know, hundred terabytes of files to try to get data on that question?
Or, or what kind of common forms does this ask the data a question take?
Sure.
So I was using like a standpoint of I've like, with a swagger that has a variable, like it's a 200 and without the variable, I'm not getting anything.
I'm like, okay, that's something.
Right.
Absolutely.
Something that I need to be aware of.
All right.
One, let me go back and see if I've ever seen a variable on a swagger before.
And then, and if I have, what's the frequency?
Okay.
I have it.
What if now I then create a test fuzz that does nothing but fuzz for, um, different variables, right?
Values and see if I can get hit on all those.
Right.
I've learned that this is now a new way to extract data.
How can that I apply it to all the data that I have?
That's very relevant.
Right.
How do I do that?
So now, now, then I'm like, okay, we extract all the, the whatever swagger dot j sounds.
And then, okay, I'm going to put together and craft a specific test that I can measure and say, okay, I'm going to put in 50,000 variable names and run this through.
Am I getting hits?
Oh, dang, you hit on two.
Okay.
It might not be a vulnerability, but now in my head, I'm like, okay, I need to be aware of this and I need to be able to then, um, update my processes to at least take into consideration.
And then if it's a new, it's a new segment then, okay, now I'm starting to measure that.
Okay.
How much time am I spending on this?
What's my hit rate for this new test that I've created that is about this one specific thing.
Wow.
Okay.
It's, you've said all of that in different parts.
Now the picture is getting much clearer.
So, so you're at your, you're saying, okay, I've got variables on the swagger file.
I'm going to scan across all these things to see where have I ever seen variables on a swagger file before?
And, and you're updating your process to maybe even wait that higher in the future and say, okay, you know, if I've got, if I've got something like, you know,
if I've got something like a swagger file and then that's X, X, Y, Z waiting, uh, rating.
And then if it has variables, oh, that's a little bit more interesting because I'm, I'm getting more.
But it also tells you how complete of a assessment you're, you're doing.
Right.
And so leave your existing, leave your existing, uh, program going, don't modify it and keep it going.
It's, it's all about testing, right?
You're all about trying to test and find new winners.
So you're put together a hypothetical test.
You're saying, okay, let's see if I do this.
Right.
And I started with, you know, 10,000, uh, 10,000 different variable names in my test.
I only got a hit on, you know, five and it was always group one, group two, group three, group four.
Well that media industry standard is just group.
So all I need to do is those 10 names and put it into the, into the, uh, into the process.
And now I've got coverage, right?
We got a process that takes one second to run and you know, it's going to find incrementally more than I did the day before.
Wow.
That's pretty lit dude.
And, and I think reintegrating all of that too is really, is really, uh, it's a challenge from a programming perspective.
And one of the things I didn't love about being an automationist back in the day was this, uh, you know, this concept of I'm spending so much time programming and it results in cool bugs.
Uh, but I, I like to spend more time, you know, staring at other people's code and wondering how to break it than writing my own crappy code.
That's going to break.
Right.
And it's a headache and whatever.
Yeah.
And most of them, you know, a lot of, I would say actually this month, majority of my time has been trying to tinker around and getting my server that one of my servers that broke back up and running.
Right.
And that's a pain, but whenever it does run.
It is.
Right.
I sit down and in the four hours, bloody bugs.
Okay, great.
So now if I can do that every single day, but I just got to get it back and thank goodness for AI.
Cause Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
I mean the, the, for me to sit down and code has a pain, but now with AI, I'm just going to get it back.
Now with AI, shoot, just, I need this, this, and this.
Thank you very much.
Copy paste.
That that's amazing.
And I want to hear about, so obviously you're using it from a coding perspective.
Um, and I, I hate to even ask this question cause we normally try to stay away from like, what programming language are you using?
You know, sort of questions.
Yeah.
I mean, what, what are you, what are you doing with all this?
Cause this is, I mean, if you're doing all this in like bash, then it's going to be insane to maintain.
It is, is that, I mean, it is all in bash, but it's all like, um,
You're a beast, man.
I don't understand how you do this.
It's so it's, it's workflow type of thing.
Right.
And then, and then bash and you know, I just basically, you know, if then, okay.
Did the pass this step, if then it's, if then steps all the way through something come out.
Okay.
Then, then, then, then, then, then simple, simple, simple.
You only focus on one small segment each time.
Right.
You've got, um, yeah.
Compartmentalized.
That makes sense.
Very, very compartmentalized.
And if somebody would look at my code and like, you are nuts, you're not a programmer.
I'm like, you're absolutely right.
I'm not a program, but it works.
And this is how I've got it done.
Right.
I was able to do it.
It goes.
So, um, but yeah, so, uh, bash is a very simple scripting language and that's very easy
for me to understand.
If I get into some type of object oriented, I'm going to be just lost.
Um, it's, it's just not.
Wow, dude.
That's legendary.
They, they, and I think it probably really speaks to the organization of the system as
well.
Um, you know, having it compartmentalized out to different pieces.
Um, so that that's really cool.
I want to go towards the, um, the, uh, working backwards from a Vong and learning how to do
that.
And then, uh, but before that, I want to talk about source, uh, uh, your data sources.
So you mentioned before, you know, you're hitting, you've got these various curated lists
that you've got.
You mentioned a crawler.
Um, security trails, any other data sources you want to kind of shout out and share with
the people.
Yeah.
Um, so, you know, whenever you're talking about paid sources, security trails seems to be,
um, top spot.
Um, I think that I do, um, yeah, maybe I'm just going off.
Whenever you start taking a look at all the different sources that you can get from, you
know, zoom, my, the showdown, uh, um, binary edge, right.
I've tested them all.
Um, and, uh, I've integrated them all.
Um, some I've cut.
Um, but yeah, so I'm, I'm doing all that.
So those are, those are the data sets.
Some are free, some are not.
Right.
Mm-hmm.
So let's go back to the, so we were talking about this.
Let's talk about, you know, how to incorporate scoop management in this whole data management,
our data science thing.
Right.
I prioritize, um, so I have a scope management tool, uh, which is basically flat file that has, um, program subdomain or CDIR, blah, blah, blah, blah, whatever the target type where target is.
Um, is it in scope?
Yeah.
What's the platform?
What processes I need to include or not?
Okay.
If, if recons, when was those, uh, processes or for pulling data, I can assign it a value of one through whatever.
And one is daily or multiple times a day.
Two is, you know, I can stage it.
So I'm using data science also to tell me, but the frequency in which I should pull from these locations.
So then I'm not wasting money on, I know it's overkill.
Um, it's overkill time.
That, but, uh, that's crazy.
It is a little over-engineered, I'm not gonna lie, but it's very efficient.
It is, man.
It is.
And querying an API all the time is gonna cost up, cost a ton, especially if you're going for these paid data sources.
Yeah.
So, I mean, I, I, you know, between data and servers, you know, I'm pushing close to $1,500 a month, right?
That's a mortgage payment.
Absolutely.
Wow.
I was gonna ask that.
Yeah.
$1,500 a month.
I mean, and, and that doesn't, you know, a lot of people would wince at that.
I know friends that are in this community that are like, ah, $10 a month for a server.
I'm like, come on.
But, um, having this whole access to this whole data service is massively advantageous.
Right?
Yeah.
Exactly.
And, and the other thing with this too, from the automation side is like, we've been talking with people on the podcast lately about the sort of trade-offs that we've seen over the past couple of years of less people focusing on recon and more people focusing on sort of, uh, diving deep and knowing the application.
Not that those are mutually exclusive, but the one thing that I miss about, uh, automation stuff is like, and I think the, to be honest, for me, the money sort of evened out either way.
But the, the one thing that I miss about the automation is like, ah, I'm gonna, you know, like you mentioned, wake up in the morning, get my cup of coffee, sit down, and then it's, it's all doing it.
And if I go to the golf course, then it's still working for me and I don't have to stress like, ah, I'm not looking for bugs right now.
Exactly.
You know?
So I do think while there is stressors of like keeping your servers up, keeping your code maintained, there's a lot of relief that comes as well from knowing that something's constantly working, something efficient, something that you've done.
Yeah.
Built is constantly working in your favor.
So that's definitely something to be considered for the people that are looking to have a little bit more of a relaxed lifestyle.
Kind of like you mentioned of like pre-retirement sort of vibes.
Um, that could definitely be a great solution.
Yeah.
I put a little commentary to that is that, uh, I will say this, like whenever I was going crazy deep dive and doing the things that I was doing, that was so much, that was rewarded so much more.
Right.
Now.
Yeah.
I've had a lot of years in my life doing it.
And there's, it was a price.
Yeah.
I'm sure you did.
Um, but, um, no, hands down, that was, that was much, much, much more profitable.
And, and I decided to go with this way cause I needed to reinvent my relationship with bug bounty.
I needed to chill out and I needed to get to another stage of life.
So I've gone this automation ish route, uh, identifies properties.
I'm going to find bugs per se.
It's going to find the opportunities to find bugs.
Um, and to the point of that, um, and you may have a little bit of this, Justin is that I love to create, right?
I love creating things and hacking is destroying.
Automation is creating.
A lot of us kind of, Hey, I want to build something and I have, because, because there's a thing, right?
You find, you find a bug, you submit it.
What residual value does it have?
It's done.
It's gone.
I've, it's gone.
Nothing.
There's nothing else that like, there's no more return.
It's not like an annuity.
And then like, you know, every year you're going to get paid and there's some incremental value of it.
No, it's done.
So, um, you know, investing into it.
You know, investing into something that helps you out.
And, you know, I don't know, maybe it's just me, just to make me feel good.
I don't know, but I enjoy.
No, I, I, I, I totally.
And obviously I'm nuts about this data stuff.
So.
Yeah.
That's, that's very clear.
Not going to lie.
John.
That's, that's awesome.
Um, great.
So we covered, we covered the, um, we covered the, the data sources a little bit, you know,
clearly you're not shying away from paying for data sources.
You're clearly trying to get a lot of coverage.
Um, you know, pulling from lots of different places and then sort of, uh, determining what is the best frequency, um, to do with that.
Uh, and then, so bringing it back around to the, how do we, how do we identify the source for our, our vulnerability?
Um, and can you tell me a bit about, a bit about that system?
So you, you, you know, you, you've let's say you've just found a vulnerability.
How are you working back and, and letting that inform what automation stuff you'll do in the future?
Yeah.
Okay.
So I get a vulnerability.
That's another.
All right.
Uh, first thing, first thing, is it a duplicate or is it, is it new?
It's a new one.
I like this though.
This is good.
Right.
Because it's a duplicate.
I'm like, shit.
Why was I not the first?
Right.
So it's a, it's a new one.
Okay.
I go through, right.
So I trace trace through, I see, okay.
How my content discovery worked.
What did it find whenever I compared to what did I do to actually discover the bug?
Right.
So it may have alerted me that, Hey, there's, you need to look at this.
And then I dive into it and I'm like, Oh, I'm putting this piece with this piece and then fully formulating what the bug is.
But then I ask, okay, is that something that can be added?
Or was this just something that I just need to make sure that I test whenever I, you know, this is something that was a one off.
So that's feedback there.
Then I go back and I say, okay, uh, when did it enter my content and how long after, how long did it take from discovery and resolution to it to get to content?
So I'm taking a look at the time differential.
Like, was my queue too long?
Was my queue, you know, it took five hours or like, or do I need to spin up another server to clear it out that queue up?
Right.
So I'm looking at the time.
Mm.
Um, then I'm looking all the way back and saying, okay.
Um, what was my data source?
Right.
Um, and that's gonna be like security trails show dance, you know, CID ranges.
Yeah.
Even, and I've got B bot and EMS running on their separate servers straight.
They're doing their own thing.
Um, I'm not doing the brute forcing right now.
Cause I just got so much, whenever I do run, I got so many targets coming in until it works.
I just don't have, I'm choking.
Um, yeah.
Yeah.
Um, so, uh, so then I traced back through and all the way back.
Okay.
It came from security trails.
Whenever, whenever it was brought, what time did the data that I find it that I find in the morning, did I find it in the day?
Did I find it in the afternoon?
Did it resolve the first time?
Did it like, sometimes I find that I get a file and it takes, it's not until the second day before it resolves and gets to my system.
Like, okay, what happened there?
Was that an operational issue?
Was it down?
Right.
Um, so I'm trying to time crunch down, uh, and find areas that, okay, where are the gaps?
Cause I don't want to be second.
Hmm.
Yeah.
So do you have like a specific timeline that you want to see there?
Like I want to see, okay, it made it through my whole pipeline in one day and I found the vuln and that's, that's the, the happy path.
Is that, I mean, what kind of metrics do you have for that?
So, so basically my goal is within 18 hours of discovery that it's in, it's in my output.
That's great, man.
That's awesome.
I love that specific number on the top of your head.
And that varies because that's on, that's on a Monday, a Saturday and Sunday is going to be completely different.
Cause your number of targets are going to be different and, and, and holidays, holiday weeks, they're different.
So all those things taken, like you can see now, I, I look for those things cause when we were doing advertising, I mean, we had to, you know, know that doing habits are going to be different on the weekends or, or on a, uh, you know, a holiday.
Right.
But same thing with work productivity and releasing new assets, the same thing, you know, your, your death teams are, you know, you're going to be different.
They're going to adjust schedules based upon the upcoming holidays.
So, you know, you know, the upcoming, you know, weekly and into a holiday, it's going to be lightweight and not to be on weekends.
Same thing.
You're going to see less stuff come up.
So.
Yeah.
That, that, that makes sense.
So, so just to summarize that, because all of these processes get, get pretty intense.
You're, you're, you found your vulnerability.
It's new.
You're going back.
You're looking at how long it takes to go through your pipeline to get to the point where it's like, Hey, uh, John, this is something you should look at, you know, that sort of thing.
You're trying to figure out what's happening there.
And then are you, do you have data on like, Hey, you know, 90% of my vulnerabilities are coming from, you know, uh, SI or SI CIDR scans on this target.
Like maybe that's something I should over lever, you know, spend more time looking into.
Do you have, have you done that sort of thing before?
Is that something you do that?
I mean, yeah, I do have one off.
I mean, it's not like I got, you know, a hundred bugs that I'm like all of a sudden looking through and find it.
But yeah, I do see, like, I mean, I like the indicators of like, Hey, what's my hit rate for a CIDR?
What, I mean, how many, how many in target when, how many IPS do I scan?
Is it really, can I prioritize accordingly?
Do you, so I guess in order to do that, you, you'd have to log all of that as well and say, okay, yeah.
You know, is there some thing you have that says, okay, I found a vulnerability on this endpoint and it's associated with this asset and it's associated with this path and this data source and this sort of thing.
So do you have like a, like a database or a file that's full of that information?
No, I should.
You think I would, I don't have that.
I mean, because usually I do it a one-off where you talk about a manual thing.
That's what I'm going to manually go through.
Right.
I know the indicators, right.
I'm more to be completely, you know, managing and then yes, you would have that, but I don't think we're, I'm at, I think that even goes to that.
That's one level.
Wow.
Do you identify a level before?
You found the, I found the bottom.
I found the endless, the bottom of the data science seek.
That's very cool, man.
There's, there's so many, there's so many possibilities you can do with all that data too.
So then taking it at that extra level and correlating like, okay, here's the vulnerability.
What's the recipe for this vulnerability?
Well, it's an API grouped, uh, um, you know, uh, sub domain, uh, on a, on a, you know, showdown source domain, uh, with a path that has, uh, a word from the, you know, you are, or from the domain name or something like that.
You know, even something like that would be able to just be like, oh man, that'd be mind boggling to see all of the data you could pull out of there.
I like that.
Um, so I think you, you covered it a little bit.
Um, and we talked about it briefly in the past, but, um, I think this is a good transition into the, the, the, um, digital marketing arena.
Cause I've got some questions about that as well.
Um, how do you apply conversion funnels?
They, the, the conversion funnel that you mentioned before to this, this book anything, is that the thing you just described before or is that something different?
No, it is.
It's kind of, so in digital marketing and direct response marketing in, in a lot of operations, there is a measurement that's called a conversion funnel.
Basically you have X number coming in and you're, you're whittling down to a certain end point.
So in bug bounty, right, you start with your total targets in and you're going to do some filtering along the way and you're going to do some processing.
And then at the end, you're hoped that what comes out at the end is going to be, which are highly focused on or what you want to, to gain.
Right.
So in conversion funnels, we used to think about how many, how many, uh, impressions do we get?
How many, how many clicks did it lead to?
How many form fields did it lead out to?
How many customers did the lead to be monetized?
How many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many
how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many, how many
we're applying this to assets in the scenario rather than users in a conversion funnel, in a traditional sales conversion funnel and say, okay, where along this funnel, the user comes in, they can land on the website.
Do they fill out the form?
No.
Okay.
So there's some sort of fall off between the user landing on the site and then filling out the form.
And then, you know, in our scenario, there's an asset.
What marketing recipe can I use on that group?
Right?
Yeah, exactly.
Do I need to change the color to the button to be red or purple or green?
Right?
Like that's where marketing goes into it.
Marketing, man.
Yeah.
It's great.
And in this scenario, it's, yeah, go ahead.
Oh, you said marketing is, is another name for hacking.
I mean, instead of hacking, I mean, it really, hacking relates to computers, marketing relates to people.
Right?
You're hacking people.
Yeah.
Wow.
Go watch, go watch Social Dilemma and then put your mindset on of like, okay, hacking people.
You get people to change their mind without them knowing.
Have you seen the movie yet?
I have not seen it yet.
That seems fascinating.
So I'm definitely going to, I'm going to have to check that out after this.
Yeah.
No.
All right.
Let me, let me get to, we have so many things in this, in this document here that I need to pick your brain on.
So I guess we'll, we'll switch over now towards the digital marketing area.
And we've sort of talked about, you know, we've talked about the content, the concept of conversion funnels, you know, with people coming in versus assets coming in and that sort of thing.
Um, I'm wondering if there's any tips that you have as a, as clearly an industry expert on digital marketing and that sort of thing.
What kind of things do people need to know when they're looking at a digital marketing platform from an attacker perspective?
Cause there's a lot of, um, lingo, uh, marketing concepts, that sort of thing.
Um, what data is important?
What's data is not important.
Um, that people need to understand for them to be able to have that sort of, uh, subject matter expert, uh, uh, approach to attacking a marketing platform.
So can you give us like, I know it's a lot cause I know I'm asking you to just like condense your whole, you know, work history and expertise in digital marketing into a thing, but what kind of things do we need to know where we're going to get the most value out of it?
So the things you need to know, uh, is like with hacking any target, right?
You need to know the industry's ins and outs, the operations, you need to know the terminology, need to know what's, um, what's important to the users, what's important to the business, right?
You need to understand the ecosystem and how that works.
Now, whenever you get into there, right.
Then you can start looking for things that are of high value, uh, that might be disguised.
Um, and, um, I guess before I get to that point, I would like to make, say is that with every ad platform, there is tons and tons and tons of documentation.
There's a lot of functionality from the point of add, you know, content creation to delivery, to bidding, to the result sets.
And there's a lot that goes on into that.
So knowing all that there's, there's areas to functionality to take a look at.
Now, by being, by being somebody that has a knowledge of, Hey, I was once a digital advertiser, I know what's important to me.
Right.
And I, uh, kind of a subject matter expert systems design, know how things should work type thing.
You combine those two, you take a step up and you start taking a look at these platforms.
Right.
And you, you can kind of see some, some areas that, uh, that, um, data shouldn't be at.
Yeah.
Highly sensitive.
That, that, that, that may, that makes sense.
So I guess without, you know, we, uh, we walk the line here on critical thinking quite often of like, give us your secret sauce and tell us about all of these critical vulnerabilities you've found on all of these companies that we don't.
Sometimes, sometimes we don't explicitly name.
Sometimes we do explicitly name, you know, but a lot of times people know what we're talking about.
Um, so I guess with that, with that line in mind there, um, what, what kind of data in those sort of environments should people be looking to, to leak or what kind of data is important in that, in those sort of applications?
Yes.
So all the ads are getting published anyway.
Right.
You know, that's one thing that I've struggled with.
Obviously you've got personal information of like the people, you know, that are, have accounts on the platforms, but like it's a highly public.
Sort of concept and somehow you've been able to extract a ton of money from these, these, you know, platforms.
So what data are you getting?
So as a consumer, yeah, it's a very public thing, right?
Just being served ads.
But so as an advertiser, right, you're in direct competition with every other advertiser, right?
That real estate space comes at a price and you're trying to get the best real estate space, uh, space for the lowest price.
Right.
And it's typically done through blind auction.
There's some public, uh, uh, auctions out there now, the blind.
What is a blind option?
Auction.
Sorry.
That's my Southern accent.
Auction.
A-U-C-T-I-N.
Yeah.
But what is a blind auction versus a not blind auction?
So blind auction is whenever you're bidding on keywords, right?
You're saying, I'm willing to spend $4.37 on this keyword.
It's a, whatever phrase match, blah, blah, blah for this demographic and yadda yadda yadda.
Right?
Sure.
Now that's my bid.
Now, if I'm a dollar over advertiser B, I'm paying way too much, right?
There's a lot of efficiency or the inefficiency is a very profitable for these companies.
Interesting.
And right, because you're in competition, you're going to be like, okay, what is, if I'm Toyota, I'm like, what's Ford doing?
Like, how, what is, what's their strategy?
How much are they spending?
How much are they paying in the blind option?
Yeah.
What are they doing?
Option.
I'm saying option.
Auction.
Yeah.
That makes sense.
All right.
So, there's a lot of, there's a lot of data that goes around that is highly sensitive whenever it's viewed from the standpoint of a customer or an advertiser's KPI.
Interesting.
So, in those scenarios, you're kind of wanting to pull data on how much people are paying for advertising and how much money they're putting into specific keywords or specific phrases or specific ads within that environment.
Cause, and maybe the ad content, you know, I guess the ad content is important cause you have to be able to know the keyword, but the ad content is going to get shown to the user anyway.
So, what you're mostly looking to do is figure out how efficiently their ads are working and what their spend is on those specific things.
So, you can butt right up to that a little bit.
Right?
Yeah.
Now, I would say, I would say this caveat right now, if you were going to Yahoo, now I'm looking there, you will find costs per, you know, bid or, you know, and that's because that's the section that's sort of leaking that information right now is a public auction.
So, I'm going to save everybody the pain and agony of going, oh, I found them right now.
So, be careful on that.
But there are, there are, there were times whenever it's a private, a blind auction and you're able to strip and maybe they'll find, you find some KPI data that shouldn't be in there.
And, um, whenever it is, uh, an issue that is, um, I guess, persistent in the overall design of all your ad display operations, you then have a bug that gets rolled out everywhere.
I see, I see.
Okay.
That, that makes, that makes a lot, a lot of sense.
And I imagine also, and maybe tell me if I'm on base or off base with this, I've done a little bit of digital marketing myself, that being able to tell the contents of an ad before that ad runs, would that be, would that be something that, you know, has high impact to a marketer to say like, okay, you know, Ford is running an ad that says, you know, Toyota, this is breakdown more than Ford.
You know, Fords or something like that.
I don't know.
You know, something like that.
Having that information in advance, would that be valuable to Toyota or is that mostly just as is going to be public information anyway?
It doesn't really quite matter.
Yeah.
You know what?
I mean, I think you can make the case because let's say I'm going to put a blitz campaign on for the holidays, right?
I don't want my competition to know what my marketing message is.
Uh, you know, this is part of my strategy, right?
I don't know.
They shouldn't know anything that I'm doing.
Uh, and any, um, any hint that that destroys the efficiency of my, so yeah, I'd be mad as hell if that was the leak as an advertiser.
Yeah.
So interesting.
I think if you have.
I've got some ad platforms that I put in the doc that I'm not going to mention explicitly, but, uh, that I, I've got some stuff on that I need to go back and revisit, I think after this conversation.
And maybe I'll, I'll hook you in.
There, there is, I mean, it, when you're talking about the advert is a cutthroat type of situation.
I mean, there's a, there's, there's a lot of, uh, like spy through.
I remember using, I mean, you're, you're trying to do anything and everything to find out what your competitors keywords are, what they're doing, what ads, what their performance was.
We use all kinds of data aggregators to be able to, they were basically crawling and screenshot and doing all that kind of stuff and providing reports.
So it's, it's, uh, it's, uh, yeah, it's almost a competitive world.
And so if you can find some information like that.
Yeah, no.
Um, yeah.
And then I would definitely spin it up as like, you know, you're, you're bread and butter, your industry, you make money from ad sales, right.
And your core moneymaker is the thing that is, uh, at risk.
No.
Hi.
Definitely.
That's Ben.
Yeah.
I'd love to see you.
I need to just invite you in.
Your bread and butter, your bread and butter is on the line here.
No.
Hi.
No, no, no, no.
That's hi.
End of story.
That's great, man.
So one of the things, one of the things that's a part of your, um, sort of hacker signature, uh, that I, that I remember you from in the live hack events is this whole concept, concept of a Moab, a mother of all bugs.
Right.
That I've heard you talk about, and there's a lot of chatter going around in the live hacking event scene when you were crushing it about, um, you know, John having some sort of secret, you know, weapon, uh, of a bug, golden goose, you know, Moab, whatever you want to call it.
Um, I'm wondering, you know, obviously in, in one or two live hacking events, you've had something like that that's just blown up and just, you've found a ton of vulnerabilities with it.
Um, I'm wondering how, how often you find stuff like this, where it's like, um, very systemic.
Very systemic.
Uh, you, you had some, some criteria, uh, criteria here that you mentioned in the interview.
You said, no, no one else knows to look for it.
It can be found on different hosts, functionality, endpoint, making it ceasefire resistant.
And it's a rating of higher critical impact.
Right.
That's what you've kind of defined.
And, and can you talk to us a little bit about your experiences with those and how often you're finding them, what you're doing to find them?
Yeah.
So, um, the, the only we were alluding to earlier about finding, you know, finding it that you find information or data that you can extract information from in a place that it shouldn't be.
And it's everywhere that is a Moab, right?
That was the key fundamental design issue that was persistent.
And it was everywhere.
Right.
It was across the, about every single place that an advertisement was displayed.
It's that's a big bug.
All right.
So the other ones, there's no, nothing has been like a Moab like that before.
It was just one issue and it was persistent everywhere.
I've been able to get into like a system and then be able to do a stream of 30 bugs.
That's, that's another.
Sure, sure, sure.
And that, that, that not quite a Moab.
I had a mini Moab, uh, um, with, uh, in the light.
It doesn't quite meet the measurement for a Moab, but it's a mini Moab.
So in, um, in that, uh, 7.02 that, that, that one, um, that's my, my first, um, um, I, I, I, I stumbled upon, uh, the YQL servers.
Everybody knows what they were at the time you had, you could interact with them.
Some queries for most part, but you didn't know exactly the basics.
Well, there was probably, I don't know, 30 servers.
I'm just making that up, but I don't know what the exact number is.
Let's say there was 30 of those servers.
And, and I found one of the servers that had an API document.
It was the only one that had an API document and that API document gave me an endpoint that then could apply to all 30 of those other, or 30 hosts.
30 hosts.
Oh man.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
And that API document led to two mediums for each host.
And then, and then, because, because the endpoints that it would then, you know, continue to, to provide, which is fully down the complete path.
There was other opportunities like SSF all over place.
So then there was another couple of bugs here and there.
So the end, the end of the day, right.
You had one API document on one host that gave you enough information to pull 75, 80 bugs.
I don't, I can't remember how many of them was, but it was, right.
It rolled out.
So it was something that applied them to everything.
Um, yeah.
Right time, right place.
Um,
Freaking, freaking Yahoo, man.
Like they rock for pay for paying that sort of thing.
And, and also for having those sort of phones, I guess in those sorts of scenarios, I'm wondering, do you, do you automate the report?
Because it's like, that's like 75 reports you gotta write that that's going to take a long time.
Yeah.
It's a lot, man.
I'm looking at this document.
You know, we still have so much that we could cover on here.
And we've had so much good content so far already.
Unfortunately, we've got to bring it to a close because I do have a stop.
But, um, John, thank you so much for coming on, man.
Is there anything else you want to, you want to shout out or you want to discuss in the last couple of minutes here?
No, I just want to say thank you so much for having me on and, um, for the content creators in this, in this space, hats off to you.
Um, oh my gosh.
Uh, I know that's a, it's a burden of love, but, uh, it's so greatly appreciated.
And, um, you know, what you guys do is fantastic.
So keep up the good work and, uh, be tuned in.
That's awesome.
Thank you so much, John.
I, I really, I really do appreciate that.
It is, it is a lot of, it's a, it's a lot of work, uh, but you get a lot of love out of it too, from people like you and, and also, you know, you coming on the show and stuff like that.
It really, it eases, it eases the load because all I've got to do is sit here and be in, you know, dump my brain of like, all right, how does he do it?
You know?
And, uh, and then get the answers.
So it's a great, it's a great experience for me as well.
Yeah.
Alrighty.
I think, I think with that, we'll close, uh, once again, John, Mr. My Own Eyes, Mr. Mayonnaise.
Thanks for coming on.
And, uh, we'll see you on the HackerOne leaderboards.
Sounds great.
Thank you very much.
Peace.
Bye.